[Music]
marvel studios moon night has some
otherworldly action which is why i'm
breaking it down with vfx supervisor
sean faden hey sean hey lorraine now
let's kick off with episode two where we
see mr knight facing off against that
invisible jackal how did you and your
team first start to approach that scene
there was a lot of weight on this scene
and making sure that it um it landed
well it actually starts in the alleyways
you've got mr knight being sort of blown
through this fence we spent a lot of
time pre-visiting this scene because it
was he had the complications of having
to have an invisible opponent the jackal
is only visible you know occasionally
during this sequence we had a lot of
storyboards that we got from
one of our main storyboard artists phil
langone it wasn't for every single
sequence but when we did get them they
were extremely helpful in the end how we
shot it was we had a stunt person in a
gray suit pushing and pulling our stunt
moon knight or oscar and layla around
for me the the most important thing to
capture for real was leaping or landing
or running we did shoot when possible
references i think that if you end up
doing too much cg throughout every
single shot you end up losing some of
the reality so we always try to shoot
with real stunts
well we're talking battles we have to
talk about the end of the series where
we see your techniques taken to new
heights quite literally with a huge god
versus god battle in cairo how did you
go about approaching that scene and
bringing it to life it was a combination
of a lot of previs some storyboarding a
lot of back and forth with our stunt
team trying to figure out what the best
flow of fight choreography was going to
be for these moments and making sure
that we were seeing you know conscious
getting to be heroic and seeing amit use
some of her crocodile related fight
moves
we actually did a lot of work um within
the chamber of the gods because we have
a scene that takes place there where
controvers are normal size which means
they're actually you know nine feet tall
we had previous all this stuff and then
we went and we shot a lot of background
plates within our set which sometimes
are just looking at like a column and
the rest will be blue screen they
created costumes for ahmet and kanchi
real costumes that moved like the real
thing that looked like the real thing
that could be lit like the real thing so
it wasn't just guys in gray suits
running around we actually had a
lightable
concho and amit in our scene and they
were able to act against each other the
scale of the two characters mainly
became an issue when we were dealing
with other actors you need to interact
with them so if oscar was talking to
kanchu then kareem who played kancho on
set would be wearing an eyeline pole to
make him look nine feet tall it was
literally two ping-pong balls on the end
of a composite rod that was attached to
his uh like a lightweight vest that our
props department made
the gods are already quite tall but then
they grow even larger how did you create
this scene at such an epic scale so
they're almost as tall as the pyramids
and they're bashing around and wreaking
havoc
created a full cg giza plateau based on
some lidar that we had gotten from
disney archives we had a lot of work
that went into sort of figuring out just
how much dust or how much light should
be hitting these characters to make them
feel big and we found was like the less
light we put on them the more that we
should have played the light falling off
on them the bigger they they felt
this is really just a tiny drop in the
bucket of all of the action in the
series looking back are there any
moments that you think fans might have
missed the series is jam-packed with
lots of cool details i don't think
you're going to catch it on the first
viewing i really think it's one of those
things you have to watch a few times to
really appreciate all the detail and
heart that went into these moments all
right well i guess i'm going to have to
go start my re-watch right now so sean
thank you so much for talking with us
well i appreciate it thanks lorraine and
everyone be sure to go watch marvel
studios moon night all episodes are now
streaming only on disney plus
[Music]